what makes humans as special you know
what's the secret of our success we have
the most expressive faces in the whole
animal kingdom
we have the unique ability to blush you
know we involuntarily give away our
feelings so so we're evolved to trust
each other yeah and even though we're
individually not that special
collectively were incredibly incredibly
smart and I think that doesn't
necessarily mean that we're naturally
good because people can also do horrible
things you know when they're working
together and there's also a real dark
sites who are friendliness you know our
group business tribal behavior I will
say if I wanted to get someone to adopt
very violent behaviors I would put them
side-by-side like you make it so that
you're you're like protecting each other
I would put an ask or visor on you make
it so then you you actually aren't
making like eye contact or camp exactly
exactly it did make me reflect on what
the United States is experiencing right
now with you very violent behavior on
the parts of certain police officers
caught on tape in response to the
protesters yes absolutely and it's so
much the opposite of what the police
should be
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks the brilliant the philosophical
and I say that with with a lot of Z
because he's literally a philosopher an
intellectual mentor of mine Rutger
Bregman Rutger welcome thanks so much
for having me and ER I look I was
looking so much I was looking forward to
today so much you know I'm a huge fan
huge fan of yours so Rutger and I first
met though Rutger doesn't remember this
very well but when he gave his TED talk
about poverty and universal basic income
in Vancouver I was in the crowd you know
watching and thinking like wow this guy
is amazing and then I I quoted you all
the time from then on that poverty is
not a lack of character it's a lack of
cash and referenced that talk sent it to
as many people as I could and then of
course your book utopia for realists
also very impactful tons of people read
it and loved it and now you have a new
book out humankind that I think is just
out now and the subtitle is a hopeful
history go ahead and tell us about what
led you to write this book so the reason
I read the book is that in the past say
15 to 20 years there's been this silent
revolution in science you know so many
scientists from so many different
disciplines think about sociologists and
psychologists and anthropologists and
archeologists have been moving from a
quite cynical view of who we are as a
species to a more hopeful view of you
know what we are and what we can be if
we actually believe and if we assume the
best in each and every one so I wanted
to connect the dots and show that there
was something bigger going on and on the
other hand there was something else as
well I started to notice actually while
promoting my previous book utopia for
realists and as you know you know the
central idea and that book is universal
basic income I had collected a lot of
evidence that
actually works you know so many
experiments ever since in the 1970s in
the u.s. in Canada and many other places
as well that show that universal basic
income is like
venture capital for the people
healthcare costs go down crime goes down
kids do better in school etc etc it's
like there's so much evidence that it
works really well so I went on a book to
her and I talked to I don't know
thousands of people about the idea and
again and again and again after 30 or
after 40 minutes I find myself
discussing not just sort of the
scientific evidence but also human
nature because that is sort of the most
common objection people have so people
people would say to you but people will
do terrible things with his money
because people are lazy and selfish
self-indulgent and generally immoral
beings is that that a summary yeah
that's what I heard again and again that
people said oh this may work on a local
scale or maybe it worked in Canada or
maybe in this place in Europe but we
don't believe it's gonna happen on a
large scale and certainly not than you
asked because human nature people are
just selfish people are just I don't
know lazy they're gonna waste the money
on drugs or alcohol etcetera
so then I realized that I actually had
to dig a little bit deeper and I
discovered that this view of human
nature this cynical view of nature is so
deeply embedded in our culture you know
it goes back all the way to the ancient
Greeks and you find it with the
Christian Church Fathers you know the
notion that were all sinners you find it
with the enlightenment philosophers or
the founding fathers John Adams you know
once wrote an essay with title all men
would be tyrants if they could and I
think that this idea that people are
just selfish had has also been at the
heart of sort of the capitalist model
for decades you know that we're just
Homo economicus that were just basically
selfish beings and I think that will
reduce the utility maximizers right
Riker we're all just counting are you
tiles but I mean it's not a it's not a
harmless idea because sort of your
theory of human nature
to produce the kind of people that
oppresses so there's one economist
Robert Frank who did these studies with
his students where I actually discovered
that if you you know you do a small test
where you sort of try to find out how
generous people are and turns out that
actually as people progress in their
study you know as they study economics
they become more selfish they start you
know behaving like Homo economicus it's
like we teach it to them so ideas I
never wear these just ideas well it's
well established and you reference these
studies in the book that what you expect
people to do you get more of like if you
have high expectations for a kid and
tell them oh you're you're great you're
smart like you'll do well then their
performance actually changes and
obviously the opposite is true too if
you say hey you're bad at this you're
terrible
yeah then their performance declines
yeah and it sounds like that's true for
our decision-making too like if we're
all told hey you're just going to be out
for yourself and maximize your own
well-being then you look around and say
okay I guess that's the way we do things
here but that that actually isn't
consonant with our nature really ins is
what you argue very very compellingly
yeah exactly and the same is true for
Social Security if you have a system
where you ask people to prove over and
over again that they're sick enough that
they're pretty depressed enough that
they're really a hopeless case and will
never get anything done in their life
and you give them a little bit of
support say food stems for example which
is another you know again it's all about
distrust we don't trust you to actually
make your own decisions yeah what are
you gonna get obviously you're gonna
make people depressed and dependent you
know it's a system that produces
dependency and this is why I was so
enthusiastic about the OVI when I first
you know read about it in 2013 2014
because it's all about trusting other
people you know and this can become a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you actually
trust people to make the right decisions
then you'll discover that the real
experts on the poor's lives are the poor
themselves right they know what they
need but your angel gotta make
and thinking about how you know how you
look at human nature I want to verify
for you two things that you experienced
Rutger number one when I was on the
trail arguing for universal basic income
people also objected based upon a point
of view of human nature I was very base
selfish lazy and negative so it wasn't
just you
and number two when I was campaigning
around the country I met so many people
who felt diminished by our dehumanizing
system of welfare benefits and food
stamps and the worst of them must have
been disability where if you are on
disability you literally have to prove
that you're unable to work periodically
in order to continue to get benefits and
there was one woman who told me about
how she wanted to volunteer in her
community but she was scared to do so
because if they saw that she could
volunteer then they might take her
disability benefits away yeah and and so
there were stories like that over and
over again where our systems end up
reinforcing a perception of someone in
their own minds also as not being able
to do the things they want to do it's
it's tragic to me like we're and and if
you present the vast majority of human
beings with this viewpoint on themselves
it's like hey number one you're a liar
and a cheat
number two you actually have like a real
problem like most people will choose
number two it's like I actually do have
like you know this genuine disability
are there physical or emotional or
mental or whatever it is you know like
most people will find themselves in that
bucket and not though I'm actually
totally bullshitting and I'm perfectly
fine and I just want that bad set of
benefits like that's just not the way
humans shaped their reality no no humans
are meaning seeking creatures you know
we want to contribute we want to be
someone in society right
no one sort of or there are very few
people who choose to live a life doing
nothing sitting on the couch
watching Netflix all day because that
makes people depressed right and
obviously we've been very good at at
sort of keeping people dependent you
know with these kind of very
paternalistic systems of social security
now that doesn't mean that we should do
away completely with social security
because you know poverty is is is a is
one of the biggest injustice as there is
in the world we just should trust people
and to build this floor in the whole
income distribution and that is true for
the US and it's also true for Europe
because you know what you've just been
describing I see this literally the same
thing in the Netherlands where maybe our
you know our welfare state is a little
bit stronger right we have universal
health care but then I mean you have
cases where people literally you know
we're fined because they were doing
volunteer work while they were on
benefits as well right because oh no you
can't really do that yeah it's it's
really this paternalistic system that is
all about distrusting other people and I
think we should completely turn that
around I couldn't agree more one
argument that I hear sometimes here in
America is that this model would work in
Europe because your societies are more
homogeneous or at least that's the
perception yeah and they look at the US
and say you know there there are too
many different types of people here
which I sense is generally like they're
talking about race really when they're
talking about yeah yeah so that so this
is certainly one thing that has come up
what's your perspective on Europe versus
the us in that regard
I'm really really skeptical of that
argument that ubi is not going to
obviously to be honest I think that the
US has you know is it might be the first
country that will implement this policy
it seems to me like a very very American
idea and people forget about this but it
was actually Richard Nixon you know at
the beginning of the 70s who almost
implemented a modest basic income you
know it almost happened and at the end
of the 60s you know everyone from the
left to the right Republicans Democrats
they all thought that this was the
sensible way forward you
the perfect marriage between left-wing
and right-wing thinking right the left
gets the eradication of poverty and a
bit of redistribution here to reduce
inequality and the right gets you know
freedom because that's what it's all
about the freedom to make your own
choices right to have a little bit of
your own venture capital so that you can
start a new company move to a different
job etc etc so it seems to me that it's
a it's a very very American idea or it's
it's it's a way that America likes to
see itself right right Europe has I
think a stronger tradition of
paternalism you know stronger tradition
of social democracy where often those at
the top say you know we want to help the
poor but we know what's best for them
right we were going to help them right
to make the right decisions and that's
really holding us back well it's one
reason we ended up naming the universal
basic income that we fought for the
freedom dividend yes where it was very
American sounding and we focus group
tested a bunch of different names
universal basic income income Social
Security for all prosperity dividend
opportunity dividend freedom dividend
and freedom dividend tested better than
anything else that we try because it's
brilliant it's absolutely brilliant you
know I've changed my mind on this I you
know in Utopia for realists I still talk
about basic income but diffident is
really the right word because income
assumes that you you know you have to
work for it but a bit you know it's a
dividend because it's a right just
because you exist because you're a
citizen of your country because you have
a heartbeat because you have the right
passport that is enough and why can we
afford this well simply because we're
already so rich right because our
forefathers worked so hard and created
all these innovations all these amazing
technologies we've got all the rents
that comes from the land we've got the
rent from you know all the buildings
that we've built together etc etc
there's so much shared capital and yeah
everyone deserves a share of that
everyone deserves a dividend from that
so you basically have a platform to
stand on
and I exist for a much better concept I
was telling people this is already your
money and one of the arguments I was
making was that your data is getting
sold and resold for billions of dollars
a year and you're not seeing a dime of
that you're generating value and are in
our society now has the wealth to be
able to do this and in the absence of
making this kind of move we're going to
wind up in the most extreme
winner-take-all economy in the history
of the world which we are already seeing
yeah in your book you go through some
examples oh I can almost see your wheels
turning when you were preparing the book
because you were trying to figure out
okay why is it that we all think that
we're terrible what are like the great
pillars of Western thought or
experiments that have established for us
all that if you leave a bunch of people
alone we're gonna turn on each other
Lord the Flies style and you obviously
use Lord of the Flies as one example it
was fascinating for you to try and go
through and inspect and re-examine each
of the major reasons why we've all taken
for granted that human beings are shitty
terrible creatures if you leave us alone
yeah well if you write a book like this
you know that you're gonna get the
response but yes but what about this
what about that what about right that's
that's the response you get all the time
so I knew that it had to be a fairly big
book and indeed I decided to start with
Lord of the Flies you know one of the
most famous novels of the 20th century
you know it's about a group of kids that
end up on an island and an inhabited
island after an airplane crash and they
have to you know set set up some kind of
society to survive and it doesn't really
work turns out that civilization is only
a very thin veneer and if you leave this
kids alone even though they went to a
really good British boarding school you
know they were very well behaved but you
know they they turn into savages at
least that's what happens in the novel
written by William Golding it was
published in the 50s and it became you
know a huge bestseller millions and
millions of kids Lord of the Flies as a
thing it's like oh he's gonna go Lord of
the Flies
it's like a shorthand did you have to
read it in school or not yes yes we did
yeah yeah yeah
IIIi read it when I was 16 or 17 or
something like that and I still remember
you know the the effect it had on me you
know I felt like uh well that's
depressing but maybe this is more
realistic as well no more Harry Potter
for me but then for this book I decided
to to see and find out whether there's
ever been a real-life Lord of the Flies
case right has it ever happened in all
world history that real kids shipwrecked
on a real island and yeah what would
have happened so yeah after a couple of
months of research I did find a case
actually in 1965 in Tonga which is an
iron grip in the Pacific Ocean there
were six kids who were bored of their
boring school and they hated the school
meals so what they decided to do is to
steal a boat and get away now in the
first night they ended up in a storm
they drifted for eight days ended up on
this uninhabited island and survived for
15 months and this how long nine months
yeah fifteen months so then the crazy
thing is that if you if you look at the
real order flies like this real story in
almost every single way it's the
opposite of the fictional Lord of the
Flies it's a story of friendship of hope
and of resilience and actually these
these guys are still friends today and I
mean hopefully you're bonded for life by
the fact you got shipwrecked together
and you didn't eat each other so now
you're now you're each other's like you
know Christmas list but we built like
the the lean-to together exactly exactly
now I mean obviously this is not a
scientific experiment right I know that
it's just one story but I think that if
millions of kids have to read about the
fictional Lord of the Flies then they
deserve to know about this story as well
and I think it's also important because
maybe you experience this as well while
you were touring is that people are just
more moved by stories than by scientific
data etc I mean data helps I love math
but in the end we human beings we are
the stories that we tell ourselves right
and for centuries we've done the same
thing after months on the campaign trail
Rutger is that I let off talking about
data and I was like and it's pretty
self-explanatory and you you needed to
shift towards stories and people and
emotional appeals and different modes of
communication as quickly as possible I
figured it out it took me months but
you're right just probably you need both
right I think what I try to do in this
book is to have powerful stories but
then also you know the research right I
try to zoom out right I try to rely as
much impossible on meta-analyses you
know where researchers take a whole
bunch of studies put them together and
to see what a bit what the bigger
picture is because I mean in science
often the problem is obviously that
especially in psychology so many so much
research doesn't replicate you know they
have one exciting study and it you know
gets to the front page of nature or of
science you know one of the big journals
but then two years later you hear well
it didn't really replicate so I wanted
to write a book that people could still
read ten years from now and then you
have to take a very different approach
also the real-life lord of the fries
flies was fascinating one other story I
found fascinating where this phenomenon
was that when you looked closely at
soldiers in different military conflicts
when they were using muskets the
majority of them apparently did not fire
at the enemy
they fired above them they pretended to
reload over and over again that you know
they essentially try to do anything they
could to look okay without firing on
each other and I found that to be
absolutely fascinating yeah yeah me too
it was a big surprise for me I didn't
know that before but turns out that
actually we've been brainwashed a little
bit by Hollywood and Netflix and you
know we've been watching too many series
like like Game of Thrones which is which
give us the impression that violence is
very difficult now obviously we human
beings we can be really nasty right on
the one hand
think we've evolved to be friendly and
there's a lot of evidence for that but
actually for millennia I was the
friendliest among us who had the most
kids and so had the biggest chance of
passing on their genes to the next
generation but we're also clearly
capable of you know a lot of nasty
things and cruel things you could even
argue that we're the cruelest species in
the animal kingdom right we engage in
Wars and ethnic cleansing and genocide
and but then we do not find that easy so
indeed if you look at the history of
warfare what you find is a lot of
examples of soldiers you know just
average soldiers who have been drafted
and who can't really fire their guns and
there's one very famous study done by an
American historian there's also a bit
controversial so let me talk a bit more
about that
his name is SLA Marshall and he found
out or at least he estimated that only
around 15 to 25 percent of soldiers
American soldiers during the Second
World War actually fired their guns
right and since then there's been a lot
of follow-up research that indeed
confirmed this that yeah it's just it's
just it's just difficult you have to be
conditioned first and brainwashed a
little bit first before you actually
manage to pull the trigger we're not
born to kill we're really not and
actually if soldiers do manage to kill
in Wars we saw this a lot after the war
in Vietnam they come back and they're
traumatized right they they have PTSD
which suggests to me that maybe you know
we're not born to do this we're
obviously capable of it but you know we
don't get a great psychological reward
most of the time actually most of the
time we actually damage something or
kill something in ourselves when we kill
someone else one thing that seems to be
universally true is that when soldiers
did take certain actions shooting
killing others taking on dangers to
themselves it often was because of a
degree of camaraderie or comradeship and
they wanted to protect the people around
them they didn't want to let someone
else down um it did make me reflect on
what the United States is experiencing
right now with you the George Floyd
killing and then the protests
afterwards and you are seeing very
violent behavior on the parts of certain
police officers caught on tape in
response to the protesters mm where
there was the 75 year old man in Buffalo
who got shoved down and cracked his
skull and I believe he's still
hospitalized there are other shots of
police officers like 'but awning
students are shooting students the
rubber bullets and one of the things
that because it was reading human kind
and then looking around at what's going
on around the world you look around and
say okay if we're basically good and not
really wired to naturally turn on each
other in these ways mmm
yet we're seeing some examples that that
very much
reflect the opposite and I will say if I
wanted to get someone to adopt very
violent behaviors a few things I would
do is I would train them and you know
you talk about trying to brainwash
soldiers in various ways I would put
them side by side like to make it so
that you're you're like protecting each
other I would put a like a mask or visor
on you make it so then you you actually
like aren't making like eye contact or
campus mean exactly by the people that
you're inflicting violence on I'd have
like a culture around around that like
where you you do get a sense that some
of these yeah like some some of these
police departments have a very very
strong culture that reflects almost like
a military unit yes absolutely and it's
so much the opposite of what the police
should be I think a real police police
officer should be a kind of social
worker right it's really important that
you know everyone in your neighborhood
you know that you know the grandmothers
and the grandfathers and the aunts and
the uncles that people just basically
trust you said there can be your ally in
fighting crime right and actually
solving real serious crime
this is what we call community policing
and I think that here actually the US
has to learn something from a couple of
European countries you know in the long
run for example like 90% of police
officers don't wear guns because the
philosophy is that if you show up with
guns and with riot gear you know what
kind of message is that you're sending
if you show up at a peaceful protest you
know in riot gear what you know what do
you want now
if you don't look at Norway Norway is
really the gold the gold standard here
you know if you look at the whole
criminal justice system also if you look
at the prisons actually which are the
complete opposite of how they've
organized everything in the US so in the
US you have these systems where you know
the taxpayer is basically paying for
institutions where people come in as
citizens and they come out as criminals
right it's like universities for crime
that's what prisons often are in Norway
they've got even worse rutger and and we
need to get rid of this in the US but
it's even worse if you have for-profit
prisons because they literally have a
financial incentive around recidivism
yeah and and lower incentives to try and
rehabilitate it's so sinister anyway
well they have in the in Norway is the
opposite and it's very strange actually
if you look at it because it goes
completely in the other direction here
you have these places where the inmates
have the freedom to socialize with the
guards they can make music you know they
they even have their own music studio
and their own music label which is
called criminal records I thought that
was particularly hilarious but then you
look at the results and indeed Norway is
the lowest recidivism rate in the whole
world you know the lowest chance that
someone will commit another crime once
he or she gets out of prison and then
you look at the financial side of the
whole thing and it turns out just like
with the ubi
it actually saves money because she
spent less on health care and you create
these law-abiding taxpaying citizens the
chance that someone will find a job in
Norway after he or she's gone to prison
goes up with 40% 40% you know in the
u.s. it goes down by I don't know how
much so in the u.s. see of these region
a lot that cost money in Norway you have
these institutions that you know also
cost quite a bit of money
actually get you return on investment
you know that it's twice as large as the
as the initial investment and I think
that's exactly the same thing with with
ubi you know ubi is also all about
investing in people so that they'll
actually become creative and they'll
start a company and you know find a job
and they you know start paying taxes etc
etc it's all about getting a return on
your investment so I think there in the
whole sort of defunct the police debate
I think that we can learn something from
these Scandinavian countries there's a
lot to learn and one of the quotes I
repeated on the trail was from a
corrections officer in New Hampshire and
he said to me we should pay people to
stay out of jail because we spend so
much when they're in jail like he saw
all of the waste and expense that went
into our Department of Corrections and
it was not rehabilitating people you
know and in these states if you come out
of jail it's very hard to find a job on
multiple levels but one reason is that
employers will not hire you that you
know there are laws around your
disclosing prior convictions and
criminal record and an employer would
just rather not take a chance yeah and
then just think about the huge waste of
talent here just to think about how many
Einsteins we lost to mass incarceration
just think about how many times we lost
to poverty you know it's just yeah you
know what I mean I agree with you Rutger
but one of the things I always try and
argue to is like you know we don't need
them to be Einstein's you know I agree I
agree I agree
ya know garbage collector is pretty
fantastic as well actually this is one
of the points that I tried to make in my
my previous book utopia free list and in
this book as well is that we need to
revalue or rethink what the really
important work is right we very often
focus on the innovators and the people
who make something new but the you know
the maintainer czar are also very
important or maybe even more important
you know there's this example that the
anthropologist David Graeber always
gives if you know if you have like a cup
you you produce it once a cup but you
wash it a thousand
right so what's more important the
maintenance or the production well
certainly during this pandemic we've
seen just how vital essential workers
are much more important than what people
think of as like oh the high-order and
life will work I mean like no one gives
a about you know about my thoughts
and feelings if you can't get food if
you can't get shelter if you don't have
someone picking up the garbage it's like
piling up yeah and everything else yeah
so I agree with you that hopefully we
can rebalance that that sense of what
work is valuable but this ye and ER this
is I think the most important expert
aspect actually of ubi is that you'll
give a huge amount of additional
bargaining power to the people who
actually do the essential work because
they can always fall back on their basic
income I got this get this question a
lot is that people say Rutger but what
you know who's gonna clean my house if
people have a basic income you know they
won't want to do that anymore and I'm
like yeah that's exactly the point you
got to pay a proper salary for people
who do really important work right
they'll they'll get more bargaining
power so their wages will have to go up
and that's exactly you know that's the
point and if you can't afford that well
then maybe clean your house yourself
right so that you learn you know what's
what's so important to you and it's such
a redistribution not only of income but
also of respect that we actually
understand what what's what's so
important yeah it values people
intrinsically and one of the the
arguments I make is like look we have to
be able to say to our kids your country
loves you your country values you and
your country will invest in you and I
couldn't agree with you more that even
with this floor people would be out
there working as hard as ever on all
sorts of things better things we'd
recognize the kind of work that people
are actually doing that they want to do
and it would make it impossible or much
much harder to exploit people the way
that people are being exploited right
now
yeah where you have people who are
getting paid subsistence wages or less
in the United States and so if you look
at some of these jobs we'd probably be
investing in automating many of them if
if they're just so punishing or
unpleasant that people don't want to do
them and that is better like that's an
upgrade you know it's like when when
people look at and this is not like you
know I worked in at a fast-food diner
myself so you know it's it's it's good
work but if people like oh look at these
fast-food jobs like oh we should try and
like preserve these jobs and it's like
really like what is like the purpose of
a job here you know if we can make that
McDonald's function with fewer people
maybe that's a positive thing like yeah
you know we don't necessarily need to be
trying to safeguard these opportunities
if there are opportunities that people
genuinely would not want to do if they
felt like they had some meaningful
choice yes I agree and this is what I
learned from traveling around a little
bit is that on the one hand I agree with
you that you know automation is a you
know something very worrying and we
should be talking about it way more but
then on the other hand we also should
not underestimate our culture is
extraordinary ability to come up with
new jobs that don't really need to exist
right or what some people call
jobs or socially meaningless jobs and so
I am I made a trip to Japan Rutger
Bregman Pro job two years ago I
visited Japan and you know what's one of
the striking things you see if you just
walk around in the city like Tokyo you
see so many jobs that don't need to
exist way more even than in the US and
and especially more than in Europe you
know there's wrote works going on for
example and there are like seven eight
people standing next to it or pointing
you the way where you have to pause like
go to the left to the right where it's
already perfectly clear you know in
which direction you have to go but still
they invent these jobs and then I
realized that if you have a society
where you know we say to people your
whole dignity and you know the way we're
gonna value you as a person it's totally
dependent on you know your job and you
really need a job otherwise we're gonna
think you're you know we're not going to
value you yeah then obviously the system
is going to create a youtube mind of
jobs that don't really need to exist
you know that you know robots could do
because that's just sort of the cultural
effect of it so that's why I started to
believe that we need to take a step
further and actually have this deeper
debate about what role work actually
plays in our society right and what is
real work yeah they know and and I all
the time talk about my wife Evelyn and
how she's at home with our two boys one
of whom is autistic and what is the
market value her work at yeah exactly
been consider it work or a job man what
about the millions of stay-at-home
parents and single moms around the
United States
do you ever family yourself Rutger I
actually don't know this about you well
I'm married but I don't have kids
I'm a young man are you a newlywed is
that recent our congratulations in order
no that's four years ago and we've been
together for 10 years
so yeah oh well well Congrats but yeah
like that there are different forms of
work that right now we don't recognize
as a quote unquote job that to me really
are some of the most important things
that we do you know like if you're
taking care of your ailing relative
that's exhausting and vital and the sort
of thing that people struggle with mmm
even if they don't have other
obligations at that time and so you know
like trying to respect what makes us
human beings to me is one of the most
important facets of universal basic
income yeah yeah I agree
[Applause]
[Music]
so look I have a question for you Andrew
what what I've been thinking about quite
a lot is how long is is this shift gonna
take right how long is it gonna take to
really push these new ideas forward if
we zoom out a little bit then you
actually see that in the 60s you know in
America people were talking about you
know ubi guaranteed basic income and it
was almost implemented what was a huge
surprise for me is that actually the US
was the first country to experiment with
these kind of radical prisons that they
now have in Norway right it's not
originally it's not a Norwegian idea
it's actually an originally an American
idea and the government of the United
States of America sent out just money
that thousands of Americans around the
country just to see what would happen I
mean today it would seem unfathomable
unfathomable that the US government
would do that but we did it yeah yeah
yeah and so I am hopeful about sort of
the shift we've seen I think in the past
five six years whether you think about
you know climate change I think people
take that much more seriously think
about inequality there's a lot more
attention for that right now and and
it's also actually striking if you look
at you know the support for these kind
of ideas the vast majority of Americans
support higher taxes on the rich agree
New Deal as an observer Rutger what do
you think happened in the United States
of America that we came this close to
having a basic income in the 60s and
then it just left the radar entirely
maybe until recently maybe like I helped
drag it back into the light but what the
heck happened over those intervening 50
years that was this close to passage and
was front and center became so it
obscured and ignored mm-hmm so there are
a couple of like a really crazy
coincidences here is that for example
the Republicans became convinced that
basic income is a terrible thing for
marriage right because they saw this
spike in divorce rates and one of the
experiments in an experiment in Seattle
turns out that later that it was
actually a statistical mistake that
happened mate so there was no rise in
divorce rates at all some of these crazy
coincidences matter but it's also so
to actually stop there for a second
Rutger because this seems like a very
proto or a pro-feminist
attack which is hey if people all have
enough money then maybe people won't
stay in marriage is that about now we
would say that's actually a great idea
you know yes we want a higher divorce
rate when people get a basic income
because that's probably a Maris ein that
people were stuck in terrible marriages
but you know it probably was not the
case in this Seattle experiment I know
that there's there's been a basic income
experiment in India where they did see a
rise in divorce rates but there's also
obviously been this huge ideological
shift since the 60s and the 70s and yeah
there was there were really these guys
have got one chapter in my previous book
about that you know think about the
economist Milton Friedman Friedrich von
Hayek who in the 50s were really in the
minority they were sort of the
capitalists resistant fighters and they
really believed in basically privatizing
everything but then they started
developing their ideas and their
institutions and they took over I think
in the 70s in the 80s they used the
crisis and then Reagan and Thatcher you
know to use their ideas and they changed
the world so I think you know as a
historian I think that real change takes
like a generation or something like that
and everything depends as Milton
Friedman himself said on the ideas that
are lying around in a moment of crisis
so that's I think why it was so
important you know that people like you
already started you know years ago with
building this movement for ubi because
it just takes time you know it just
takes time and there will be a moment
when suddenly ideas that used to be
dismissed is unrealistic and
unreasonable and crazy can subtly move
into the mainstream and make the march
through the institution's right but they
have to be in the agenda first and that
takes a lot of hard work and patience
but yeah that's that's why you see if
you zoom at you you've had a hand in
history Rutger I guarantee you 100% have
because even your TED talk
ended up impacting many people that I
ran across
and me obviously and then I champion
this and you're seeing now millions of
Americans come our way we're now the
vast majority of Americans support
emergency cash relief to help address
this pandemic and one of the arguments I
made because I completely agree with you
that Milton Friedman and the cult of
shareholder value and all that stuff
really like overtook a lot of American
thought now is that somehow we have been
brainwashed over the last 50 years to
think that somehow we exist to serve the
economy and that yet we're all like
inputs into this machine yeah and if you
look at someone like Martin Luther King
he supported basic income and was
fighting for it when he was killed and
we now have a national holiday around
his birthday which I don't know if
you've spent enough time in the States
to know this is how it goes but like
every year his birthday comes and it's a
holiday and all the kids get school off
and then there are these snippets of him
speaking generally that I have a dream
speech or that they'll be just this that
this set of messages around racial
equality yeah and I've been arguing it's
like why don't they play his everyone
should get a guaranteed income speech
they don't want you to hear that yeah no
they don't and the the last 50 years
have really been a complete victory for
this market-based thinking and the
question is how does the pendulum swing
the other direction yeah I'm very
optimistic that the pendulum is swinging
the other direction very quickly because
of the realities that were faced with
particularly in the u.s. now I don't
know how the situation is in the
Netherlands but we're facing
depression-era levels of unemployment
yeah yeah well it seems to me that in
the u.s. there's often this what I think
is a very stupid debate about capitalism
versus socialism or the market versus
the government as if that is sort of the
opposition is there us this whole
generation of thinkers intellectuals and
politicians that you know grew up during
the Cold War and this is sort of the
black and white
view they have when they think about the
economy and politics and I think that's
nonsense and that's also why I like your
approach of sort of yeah humanity first
and human centered capitalism right if
you look at you know the model that we
have in other countries or in the US and
the UK in the 60s you have much higher
taxes on the rich and yet stronger
economic growth and stronger innovation
as well so maybe these things can be
true at the same time if you have
something like Medicare for all
you know universal health care that's
actually more efficient you know it
helps to make budget work better you
know it's cheaper yes and it delivers
better results and you have it in pretty
much every developed country except the
US and even conservatives in Canada and
the UK they love it they absolutely love
it right conservatives would never dream
of you know going against the NHS in the
UK actually they use the NHS to sort of
best the European Union and say okay
we're going to get out of the EU and
then give more and money to the NHS
right that's what the populace that in
the UK so I I never liked this this
discussion that you so often have about
capitalism it's a socialism in the u.s.
I think it's totally stupid it is so
dumb and destructive because you wind up
in this ridiculous incoherent
conversation I tried to express this
point of view during one of the debates
and universal healthcare is so good for
the economy on so many levels not just
because you'd end up rationalizing the
costs but how many people in the United
States you don't know this but I do how
many people in the United States have
thought about starting a business or
doing something independent and then
frozen their tracks because they didn't
know what they're gonna do about their
health care well I guarantee you
millions because in America like your
health care coverage is tied to your job
and so you're like well can't do
anything to jeopardize that and they
even have a term for it it's called job
lock so there's a ton of job lock in the
United States it's stifling
entrepreneurship and risk-taking and job
switching like if you were to get
healthcare off of this employment
basis it would be this enormous economic
catalyst in the u.s. it's just good for
business and creativity and
entrepreneurship and humanity yeah and
it's the right thing to do and our
system is is a complete mess on multiple
levels yeah so so one of the the big
questions is how the u.s. is going to
end up making that transition but the US
has a lot of legacy structures that are
going to be very difficult to reform
yeah there's one thing actually where
the US has been pretty great in terms of
having an ambitious and robust state
which is when we talk about innovation
now the reason that the US has invested
a lot in sort of radical and fundamental
innovation actually more than European
countries is because they also always
call it defense or the military right
there's so many of the fundamental
innovations in the past couple of
decades have come out of military
research there's this wonderful
economist I think she's one of the great
thinkers of our time right now Mariana
matsukata Italian economist who's
pointed out that you know every sliver
of fundamental innovation in the iPhone
you know everything that makes it a
smart phone instead of a stupid phone
has come out of research you know done
by researches that were on the
government payroll you know either
you know funded by European grants or
mostly by the US military
so touchscreen you know voice
recognition system battery internet
mobile technology you name it everything
that makes it a smart phone now does
that mean that we don't need Apple or or
other companies like that obviously we
need them right it's it's great if they
use these innovations and make a great
product out of that but then let's at
least let them pay taxes right so that
we can fund the new round of innovation
in green technology for example so I
think this is sort of an example where
it's it's become so perfectly clear that
it's stupid to think in this opposition
between the market and the state right
they actually need each other you know
the market needs sort of the bold
venture capitalists that really can use
a huge amount of money you know to put
in fundamental research and and
obviously there's got a lot of gonna be
a lot of failures there
as well right just to say I mean you're
an entrepreneur you know that Solyndra
or something like that yeah I mean
they're casualties that happens but
people forget this you know
Elon Musk he received like five billion
in US government funding and him as the
as the model of entrepreneurship
he's like the real-life Tony Stark but
but he he's very open about the fact so
yeah
yeah it's great it's great I mean it's
it's not I'm saying that oh you know
musk is it's not something we should
blame and we should have applauded him
for this right is that greed because
he's trying to solve the biggest
problems and if you're gonna solve the
biggest problems the fact that the
government supported you is fantastic I
mean something actually worked yeah
exactly
but then the problem with with this is
that we we remember Solyndra right when
a government investment goes wrong but
we forget about you know the fact that
actually the US government invested a
huge amount of money in Elon Musk right
and and in a SpaceX and in test line you
name it and the program that's lenders
associated with I believe got paid back
fully anyway like it wasn't even a net
loser but that just speaks to the nature
of our politics in the US where it's
become much more about scoring points
and less about effective policy you know
the the concern that we have here in the
states is that DC is so far behind the
curve and unable to refresh itself or
update itself and that our
competitiveness is happening in spite of
our government rather than being led by
it in many many regards you know I mean
it's one reason I ran for president is
the modernization of how we do things in
the US including basic income which
strikes me as like the next step of the
way we get resources into people's hands
I want to return to the book and for
those of you watching the video it's
like this is what it looks like this is
just proof of human kind
hopeful history so so when you were
doing this research like it is very
interesting to me about how how you
almost had to like
combat your own training we're like
we've all been trained so thoroughly
that people stink and that that if you
put us in circumstances that are
uncontrolled then like bad things will
happen and then yet you were and then
you you were digging in trying to figure
out it's like wait why do we think that
like what are like the major touchpoints
debunked some of them you can textual
eyes to others you introduce new stories
and one of the the things that you took
from it which I thought was really
interesting was that there is like a
very very small subset of people for
whom violence and bad behavior is not
wholly unnatural and unfortunately a lot
of those people wind up finding
themselves in positions of authority in
our modern life and that this was one
explanation an offer as to why certain
atrocities have occurred or certain like
you just you know like examples
obviously of cruelty and inhumanity
if you put it that way
[Music]
so so where are you now Rutger like have
you convinced yourself about the
essential goodness of humanity and I
agree with you that I agree with you on
on so many levels just about everything
you write and argue I agree with so some
of the things that I think most everyone
can agree on it's like look expectations
actually influence behavior and if you
go around telling people they're
terrible then and utility maximizers and
they might actually act like that but if
you tell them they're actually good
people and care about their family
members and neighbors and will do the
right thing and in most contexts even if
they don't have like you know person
behind them with a stick like like ready
to punish them if they don't do the
right thing you'll do the right thing
most of the time like I think that
actually ends up improving behavior for
the vast vast majority of humans I think
that having structures in place that
imbue us with the sense of confidence
that people believe in us and are
investing in us and trust us to make our
own decisions is fundamentally
empowering in the right way to go and
we'll end up producing the next level of
human progress and advancement now I do
think that they're they're like people
listening to this or watching this well
are asking this very same question that
I asked myself and I'm asking you now is
like like do I really believe that
people are good innately and that some
of the evils I see in the world are a
result of like a handful of bad actors
gaining control and these cultures of
like reinforcement that enable people to
do terrible things
mm-hmm well I wouldn't say that people
are naturally good we're not angels
we're clearly capable of a lot of nasty
stuff you know jealousy aggression you
name it but we have evolved to work
together and to connect with each other
you know you can ask the question what
makes you most
being so special you know what's the
secret of our success why do we build
pyramids and spaceships and you know why
have we conquered the globe and why not
the bonobos of the gorillas or the
Neanderthals and and what biologists now
think is that it's actually our capacity
of friendliness that's really our true
superpower because you know individually
we're not that smart
we're not that special if you do an
intelligence test and you let a human
top layer of around two years old
compete with a pig then often the pig
wins so don't eat bacon because pigs are
smart right but that's another book if
you do like a boxing match with a
chimpanzee you know you're not gonna
have a nice experience you know you're
gonna be smashed basically so we're not
very strong we're not that smart
compared to other species but we can
just collaborate and work together on a
on a on a skill that other animals just
can't and there's this saying from Isaac
Newton you know the great physicist who
once said that if we had seen further
than others it was by standing on the
shoulders of giants and I think that's
wrong actually I think that if human
beings have seen further than others
it's because they're standing on the
shoulders of dwarves we're just a lot of
doir standing on top of each other and
that makes it so smart right there's
there's one really wonderful example
from the anthropologist Joseph Henrich
that I use in the book as well where he
says well imagine a planet where there
are two sort of tribes the one tribe is
called the the copycats and the other
tribe is called the geniuses now the
geniuses are really smart you know their
ID Stein's they come up with brilliant
inventions on their own but the problem
is is that they're not very social
they're not very friendly so if they
invent something they don't share it
with with their friends now this sounds
like me as a kid but then the copycats
they're there they're not that smart
they're a little bit more like me but
they do like to share you know what they
read what they know what they find out
what they discover so very when when a
copycat you know when there's this
exceptional event that a copycat comes
up with something new then quickly
everyone knows about it now if you let
these two tribes sort of compete in
history what you actually discover is
that
the copycats end up with way more
innovations than the geniuses because
genius is well they invent a lot but
they just don't remember it well what we
have is cumulative culture you know we
we we built languages we built all the
kinds of innovations etc and even though
we're individually not that special
collectively we're incredibly incredibly
smart and I again by the way this is a
philosophical argument for you VII for
ever for a freedom dividend because it
basically says look our prosperity comes
from the collective right it's because
we're just so good at working together
and I think that doesn't necessarily
mean that we're naturally good because
people can also do horrible things you
know when they're working together and
there's also real dark sites who are
friendliness you know our group business
or our tribal behavior blazer yeah
exactly we do a lot of the most nasty
things in the name of friendship and in
the name of loyalty and in the name of
comradeship this is exactly what yeah
the dark dynamic that you see in history
and maybe now also in the u.s. you know
this extraordinary get this in-group
out-group behavior that you know just
grows and grows and grows and what you
need then is actually to try and ignore
your intuition and maybe zoom out a
little bit use your rationality and
think hey wait a minute those other
people and those other group direct you
know they're quite similar to me you
know they're they're also just human
beings with the same you know intuitions
and desires etc so you wouldn't call us
the necessarily like the good humans but
you would call us the collaborative the
sharing yeah the the group ish yes yes
and and here is also interesting that
sometimes if you want to do the right
thing the good thing you actually have
to go against your own friendliness
right if you look at you know the heroes
in our history the people who really
went against the status quo they were
not that friendly they were often
described as nasty and is difficult I
mean we were talking about Martin Luther
King nowadays he's like this hero he's
like this saint and you know you
have a you get a you get a free day in
the u.s. oh we all love Martin Luther
King actually back then he was very very
controversial you know a lot of white
Peter was a reticle yeah people know him
but that's what we forget right that's a
proof of that memory when it comes to
these kind of things so often progress
doesn't come from friendly people you
know it often comes from unfriendly
people who are willing to go against the
status quo now that doesn't mean
everyone should be unfriendly right I
think that in any movement that there
are a lot of when you raise that in
addition to Martin Luther King were
Steve Jobs and Bernie Sanders no offense
Bernie Bernie's a great guy just two
people that just popped into my mind
yeah like folks that you don't think of
as warm and cuddly but they they moved
us forward yeah yeah and then I mean you
need other people as well right any
movement needs as a whole variety of
roles you need people who are willing to
be dragged away by the riot police but
then you also need people who are you
know really good networkers and are able
to build coalitions and actually bring
people together again right and who are
willing to make uncomfortable
compromises to at least get something
done so often we we have this preference
for a particular kind of activism we're
like oh I love Andrew yang but I don't
like Bernie Sanders or I love greater
than Burke but I hate extinction
rebellion but what if all of us actually
have a role to play right what if what
if we all have a role to play yeah yeah
it's kind of wonderful and magical
Rutger but you know on this journey like
I meet folks who are all just playing
this very distinct remarkable role and
we're all different from each other one
we're all pushing in the same general
direction I certainly feel that way
about universal basic income and I want
to support your depiction of humanity
from all my time on the trail the vast
vast majority of the people I met and
these were people all walks of life all
over the country you know very very
rural communities you know like no
traffic light and all the way up
you know to the the big cities the vast
majority of the people I met were good
open-minded cooperative friendly for
sure you know like I show up in so many
towns that you know just like just me
and my team in the rental car and just
like pop out and and speak at the cafe
or the home or the union hall and it was
great like there were so many wonderful
people and even people that maybe
disagreed with me were very happy to
hear me out and would say like thank you
for being here like you know that like
that that sense that human beings are
generally open and caring and communal
was borne out by my time on the trail
like that that's one of the major
feelings I've had over the last number
of months and years you probably had the
same set of experiences because you've
travelled the world whereas I've been
all over the United States but I have to
say I have not left a country in quite
some time because yeah well if you want
to lose your prejudices travois
is a great medicine it's relatively easy
to hate or dislike people who are far
away you know that you just see their
Twitter profile and then they're like
these abstract people you know the
immigrant far away or the Democrat or
the Republican blah blah blah it's
really difficult to actually hate
someone who's standing in front of you
because human beings have evolved for
face-to-face contact right we have the
most expressive faces in the whole
Animal Kingdom we have the unique
ability to blush you know no other
primate does that we do it you know we
involuntarily give away our feelings
which is I mean I think that's
fascinating that that has been an
evolutionary advantage for us I think
it's the reason is that it helps to
establish trust and we also have very
unique eyes right if you compare our
eyes with like all the other primate
species and they're like 200 primate
species in total we are the only ones
that have white around our eyes so I can
see you
at me right now and it's just easier to
follow our gazes you know while with
chimpanzees or bonobos that's that's
much much harder to see what they're
actually looking at it I never did trust
those bonobos those are relatively
friendly did you know that bonobos are
like these they're sort of like they're
not casino phobic but they're seen you
know how do you say that philia is they
just love strangers well often happens
if you have like two groups of bonobos
and they meet each other for the first
time is that they have an orgy
you know they now I'm not saying we have
to do that but there's actually quite a
lot of things we can learn from the
bonobos so where we were evolved to
trust each other so that we can see
where we're looking we can see how our
face is yeah express emotion yeah and
that's why it's going to be on the trail
right to actually go out and meet other
people just to remember that you know
what we see of each other on Twitter and
Facebook or on the news that's not
reality and you know this is this is the
problem I think that those at the top
you know the cynical rulers in power
right who want to keep the way--the you
know keep things the way they are right
now they want you to watch as much CNN
as possible they want you to watch this
too much fox news as possible because
they know that you know if you follow a
lot of the news then you are gonna be
more cynical and more scared and it's
simply easier to rule people who are
scared and it's it's more difficult to
rule people who have a more trusting
attitude to life because they're like
well maybe we can just do things on our
own
right maybe we can live in a genuine
democracy where you know average
citizens just and get to ever say as
well so throughout history of everyone
$2,000 a month and that would be a-okay
yeah yeah ya know it's it's a dangerous
idea I think that those at the top I've
often been afraid of the of the idea of
freedom for everyone because they're
worried that they won't be necessary
anymore
I agree with you I think that
we do have a set of institutions in
place that don't trust people and that
that's fed into our leaders and our
media and policy to me running on
universal basic income it strikes me as
so obvious I was like we should totally
do this by the way if we don't do this
we're but we should totally do
this for like a multitude of very
beautiful human reasons not and the fact
that so many folks who are in positions
of power just resisted it so mightily
variety of reasons it's like why are you
resisting this like what's wrong with
Skinner food money we should have done
these decades ago yeah so I I couldn't
agree with you more that there's like
that there's a strange tension or
disconnect between trusting people and
how we're organizing our society right
now
[Applause]
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens if you are like me you
eat food every day but then you've
noticed that you're not getting a whole
lot in the way of greens and vegetables
and you think like him maybe I'm missing
something and enter athletic greens they
sent me their package it was delightful
you know like there's a sense of
accomplishment every time you drink it
because you're like oh I can sense my
body's getting something that it has
needed and wanted that I have been too
lazy to actually get for it because I
have a feeling most people I like me
where it's like you lead vegetables if
they're in front of you but like are you
really gonna seek them out like are you
really just gonna go to the freakin
vegetable aisle in the grocery store and
be like oh yeah sign me up for these
like that that's not really the move you
know so so so if you are like me and you
want to experience the nutritional
benefits of vegetables in a convenient
way to get athletic greens it's pretty
much exactly like what it just sounds
like it's like a shake drink made of
greens and if you go to athletic greens
calm / yang to claim our special offer
of 20 free daily travel packs with your
first purchase
that's a $79 added value of athletic
green goodness so that's athletic greens
calm / yang I'll add that these actually
tastes pretty good too having tried them
it's like um do you a packet poured in
some water shake it up and it tastes
great so athletic greens calm slashing
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think about the danger of
the corruption of power you know because
this is one of the findings that I came
back to again and again during my
research is that power is like this drug
where you know you put people who are
powerful in a brain scanner and they're
the regions that are involved with
empathy they don't really work that well
anymore they don't blush anymore I mean
I think the idea of like Boris Johnson
or Wilson era or Trump blushing I mean
we think we find it hard to imagine so
power is this very dangerous thing and
nomadicant together has already knew
this so they had this strong culture
where we're homeless was really
important right where you sort of yeah
make jokes about yourself and you were
not sort of allows by the group to boast
and say oh I'm so great and blah blah
blah because they knew that power was a
dangerous thing
but now we've ended up in this society
where it's not survival of the
friendliest anymore but it often seems
to be survive of the shameless and yeah
I guess this is the problem that we run
into again and again as a society is
that we just find it hard to control
those in power and to make sure that
they stay humble it's a real problem and
you know I saw your research into how
power reduces empathy and changes the
way your brain is wired mm-hm and it's
consistent with my experiences frankly
interacting with tons of very very
powerful people like the best of the
powerful people still have a degree of
humanity hmm I do think that there's
some overlap with being a woman or with
being a part of a group that frankly
like doesn't see itself as powerful you
know with every type of interaction
where they get reminded of what it's
like to be on the other side more often
they
if you are like a you know a powerful
man or a powerful white man depending
upon the context but but I think that
the brain damage is real and I've been
trying to figure out how to combat it
you know one thing I'm for is term
limits because I think well if you're
gonna get brain damage by power let's
just have you in there you can do a few
things and then we get you out really
bad that's screwed up yet yeah or maybe
there's some kind of exercises that we
have our leaders do that try to keep
them human
but and I I've experienced a very
watered down version of this record
because I'm obviously like you know it's
like I'm in my home just like many other
people but but even for me I saw my my
attitudes and behavior getting pushed in
a particular direction as the campaign
grew yeah and and one of like the most
basic things was that you know I've run
companies and it was always very
important to me to know who was at my
company you know it's like I wanted to
interview anyone we hired like etc etc
and then in in the this candidate mode
I'd be running for office and then I'd
show up in an event and there'd be like
people on my my team that I'd never met
and and there were a number of reasons
for that because there was just like the
practicality is like look like you know
you're doing all the stuff and like we
had to like hire people and like I got
it
and so then there was like this sense of
like it changes like your interactions
with people in some some respects like I
I don't think I ever really like got the
brain damage that power give but I can
very very clearly see how it would
happen yeah I reckon it's not you why
don't you recognize that and you just
have to notice it happening within
yourself and I think you have to
surround yourself with people who are
not you know too impressed with what you
do and that you just remember that you
know you're a product of circumstances
and of the great work of so many other
people right so writing a book for
example its base I can only do it
because there's so many Bri
specialists you know anthropologists
sociologists philosophers economists etc
even brilliant work so now I can make a
synthesis of it but I can't do it
without so many of my colleagues and my
editors and my correctors etc etc so
it's really a group effort but it's
something that you need to remind
yourself of and I think it's also
important to have a yeah have a sort of
a culture there's there's a little bit
of a difference here I think between the
Netherlands here and the United States
we're in in the Netherlands we often see
success as a crime right is that there's
a bit more of a stronger you get a get
at Aryan culture we tend to be
distrustful of successful people and
that has its downsides as well I think
it's it might be one of the reasons why
we have fewer like really globally
successful companies I don't know
someone should do a PhD on that but it
has real benefits as well because you
tend to have politicians who I don't
know who are maybe a little bit humbler
in America it's a problem for sure and
I'm very interested in systemic ways to
address this problem because I think
it's really important yeah like that
there should be policies around it
because having the wrong leader who's
sort of losing their humanity Lincoln
positions of power is is terrible yeah
you we're seeing that a bit with these
protests to where you can sense that
there are some local authority figures
who aren't terribly empathetic anymore
yeah or to the extent they're expressing
an emotion it's like like why are you
persecuting me and mine like you know
why why do you why are you demonizing
like my department or what not or
whatever it is like you know it's like
that they're not seeing the fact that
folks are suffering in their community
or around them or that there are
legitimate issues and grievances so
there there were crimes so there are
because that this to me is a very
important issue Rutger is like how the
heck do we try and reverse the
transformation that power exerts on
people yeah
have you looked in this whole idea of
participatory democracy because I think
that's very much connected to your bi I
actually one of the reasons I wrote this
book is as I said you know I I started
to realize that I needed to dig a little
bit deeper and you know ask the more
fundamental question of what are human
beings really like but uh you know a
friend and colleague of mine as a
Belgian philosopher David Byrne Rye
Brook and he had just written a book a
couple of years ago called against
elections where he says we need to move
towards a real or genuine democracy
where you don't just have the right to
vote every I don't know three or four
years but you actually often become a
politician yourself right you're just
randomly elected for example just like
the Greeks did I mean that was the
original Greek philosophy of what a real
democracy should look like they still
that's called a deliberative democracy
and so he had written this book with a
huge amount of examples and experiments
that have been done you know again ever
since the 1970s that actually show that
this works right so you bring together
people around the table whether they're
left-wing or right-wing rich poor young
old you let them have a discussion about
really controversial subjects you know
whether it's you know drug policy taxes
abortion you name it and often they come
up with sensible compromises
it's very pretty amazing if you give
them access to experts as well and it
really works and I think sort of this
vision of democracy is also and also
relies on a different view of human
nature right so it's it's very much the
same as with with the obyeye I think you
can get there once you start looking at
other people in a different way if you
see them as these lazy disengaged people
who are not interested in politics and
only care about their I don't know their
their Netflix in their Amazon Prime
account and you know then and they're
just I'm a big believer in the wisdom of
crowds and the wisdom of people and to
me we certainly
can't do that much worse than the
decisions that are being made by like
the detached elites who are frankly like
you know like running us into the ground
at least you know like on many of the
biggest issues of our day so I'm a huge
fan of that reimagining of democracy and
empowering people to make decisions that
would work for them in their communities
I think universal basic income is hand
in hand in this it's like we're gonna
make you a genuine stakeholder in our
country we're gonna invest in you and
your children and then you should be
able to determine where our resources
are going in a significant way because
who's gonna make a better decision you
or some like you know hundreds
away exactly who's then going to end up
you know like feeding resources into a
pipe and then the pipes gonna be like I
don't trust you that proved to be
deserve this or yeah yeah so so I'm a
big believer in that vision yeah that's
that's good to hear I'm in general I've
became a become a bit more skeptical of
of experts right even though sometimes
people announce me as oh he's an expert
on this or an expert on that but you
know the real experts on people's lives
are people themselves and we now have
created this whole what we call the
knowledge economy where people have a
lot of knowledge and they try to make
simple things more complex so that then
we need them right all these bureaucrats
and managers to manage all this
complexity but then maybe you should
just go back to school and think about
you know do we actually need all that
complexity right think about health care
for example we've made it so
extraordinarily complex right just the
whole insurance system does it really
have to be this way or can we just go
back to a more simple simpler system
that you know if I look at the
Netherlands in the 1980s it was much
simpler you know it was just yeah you
just try to help someone who's in a
difficult situation do we need a huge
amount of innovation there do we need a
huge amount of new apps there and new
management philosophies in blah blah
blah or do we actually need to go back
to basics and be a little
little bit more skeptical of all those
experts who give TED talks her - and say
well I've found the new big thing it's
like that that that Dutch entrepreneur
that you cite and to make it simple as
difficult and to make it difficult is
simple or make it yeah I screwed that up
yeah to make it difficult is simple yet
but to make it simple as difficult yes
that's it that's his philosophy and
indeed he built this quite big health
healthcare organization with self
directed teams of nurses now is fifteen
thousand employees it's got births or
which translates as neighborhood care
and yeah they deliver health care at a
cheaper cost higher quality higher
salaries for the employees it's like
win-win-win-win-win it's it's like way
better they own the all the competition
and again it shows you that sort of this
whole debate about capitalism versus
socialism is a little bit nonsense
because here you have this organization
that is obviously funded with taxes but
then you know is is you know really
decentralized and people just have the
freedom to do their job in the best way
possible I think there's a really a
marriage possible here between two
different visions yeah I mean to me the
spectrum really needs to be either human
or inhuman and our goal is to humanize
our economy and our planet as fast as
possible and you are a massive leader
and champion of humanity Rutger there
are millions of people that look to you
for edification and inspiration and I'm
one of them and I just want to thank you
so much for the incredible work you do
it is true I'm with you it's like my
goal is to try and make some progress
and then get the hell out of the way you
know what I mean like like it's not like
oh I want to be crouching like like
making all the decisions it's like I
want to help you make your decisions for
yourself and that's a vision that we
have to make real as quickly as possible
I totally agree you should come over one
time here in the Netherlands you know we
need you here I would love that
and congratulations Rutger on his
awesome new book humankind a hopeful
history his last book was a best-seller
I'm sure
this one will be too you should
definitely check it out it will uplift
you it makes you more optimistic about
what's possible and about human nature
thanks so much Angela I really really
enjoyed this me too yeah come on
Netherlands we'll do it again well do
this again anytime man you can be like a
freakin regular you don't even need to
have you know written a book that you
want to talk about we can talk okay yeah
they know you're always learning you're
always finding out new stuff and you're
one of the world's foremost champions a
universal basic income you know we have
to get this done
[Music]